digamos que tenemos una agencia de autos
y hay trabajando allí 11 vendedores muy
bien tenemos 11 vendedores además
tenemos un registro de cuántos autos
vendió cada uno de estos vendedores
durante la semana pasada ok entonces
digamos que aquí tenemos nuestro primer
vendedor que déjenme hacerlo con más
cuidado tenemos primer vendedor segundo
tercero cuarto quinto sexto séptimo
octavo noveno décimo y el último muy
bien el número once entonces digamos que
este registro lo vamos construyendo de
la siguiente forma no sé a lo mejor el
primer vendedor vendió cinco luego el
segundo vendió cuatro luego vendió diez
luego quizás cinco etcétera y así
seguimos construyendo toda esta lista lo
importante aquí no es que tanto
vendieron sino esta información que
viene porque después de esto nos dice
que la mediana de los autos vendidos
6 es decir cuando nosotros hacemos el
conteo aquí tenemos bueno 11 casillas
verdad eso quiere decir que la posición
central vale 6 1 2 3 4 5 aquí en esta
posición central verdad aquí tenemos 5
acá tenemos otros 5 en esta posición
vale 6 verdad porque es impar si fuera
parte tendremos que haber hecho el
promedio pero como es impar podríamos
garantizar que en efecto el vendedor
desde el mediodía es el que tiene la
sexta posición vendió exactamente 6
autos muy bien y además sabemos nos dan
la información de que el rango de los
autos vendidos es 4 verdad es decir si
aquí nosotros tenemos digamos el máximo
verdad este va a ser nuestro máximo y
este será nuestro mínimo entonces el
rango el rango se calcula como
el máximo el máximo menos el mínimo
verdad y ese rango nos dicen que vale 4
así que ahora te voy a dar una
afirmación para este reto lo que tenemos
que hacer es responder algo respecto a
esa afirmación y la afirmación es la
siguiente al menos un vendedor pudo
vender más de 10 autos entonces la
pregunta es es cierta esta afirmación o
será falsa o definitivamente no
podríamos decir si es verdadera o falsa
ok entonces tenemos que determinar si es
verdadera verdadera o si es falsa la
afirmación o si definitivamente no
podemos saberlo
sabemos entonces como siempre te voy a
invitar a que hagas una pausa trates de
reflexionar todo lo que puedas sobre
este problema que de verdad está muy
divertido y después lo resolvemos
nosotros juntos
así que suponiendo que ya hiciste una
pausa ya reflexionar sobre el problema
vamos a tratar de resolverlo porque
además este problema de verdad que está
muy divertido
entonces el primer detalle que debemos
considerar es que al menos un vendedor
vendió exactamente 6 autos y eso lo
dijimos hace un momento porque teníamos
11 vendedores y la mediana vale 6 verdad
si tuviéramos un número par por ejemplo
10 o 12 entonces la mediana se calcula
como el promedio de los dos que quedan
en medio verdad sin embargo aquí el que
queda en medio solo es 1 y por lo tanto
algún vendedor vendió exactamente 6 muy
bien
así que una forma de resolver este
problema es de la siguiente
digamos vamos a hacer lo siguiente que
pasaría por ejemplo si el mínimo el
mínimo de las ventas fuera exactamente 6
por supuesto que no puede ser mayor
verdad porque al menos uno vendió 6
verdad y este como está la mitad no
puede ser que a lo mejor por ejemplo
aquí haya alguien con 7 verdad entonces
nosotros sabemos que el digamos el
mínimo tiene que ser algo más 6 qué
pasaría si es exactamente 6 bueno
recordemos que el rango el rango nos
dicen que vale 4 verdad y el rango se
calcula como el máximo menos el mínimo
que en este caso es 6 de aquí podemos
concluir sin ningún problema que el
máximo tiene que ser 10 verdad porque 10
menos 6 es 4 entonces el máximo en este
caso vale 10 muy bien entonces aquí
podemos observar que no se puede ver no
se puede un valor mayor para él
el mínimo verdad dijimos que si el
mínimo por ejemplo fuera 7
entonces ya no coincide con que al menos
uno de ellos vendió seis verdad y sin
embargo si por ejemplo disminuimos el
valor mínimo digamos por ejemplo 5
entonces el máximo también tiene que
disminuir disminuir entonces
necesariamente el máximo es a lo más 10
y no puede haber un vendedor que haya
vendido más de 10 autos entonces con
este argumento podemos garantizar que
nuestra afirmación que pusimos aquí es
falsa es completamente falsa otra forma
por ejemplo de resolver este problema es
suponer lo contrario es decir vamos a
suponer que el que al menos vendieron 11
digamos que supongamos supón suponemos
digamos vamos a suponer que el máximo
digamos fuera
muy bien digamos al menos uno más de
estos diez autos qué pasaría si alguien
vendiera al menos uno más de estos autos
entonces nuevamente el rango lo podemos
calcular verdad que es 4 debería ser
igual al máximo que es 11 menos el
mínimo el mínimo entonces que hay que
restarle a 11 para que nos dé 4 pues eso
tiene que ser 7 verdad entonces el
mínimo tiene que ser igual a 7 pero eso
como ya lo habíamos dicho no puede ser
porque la mediana es 6 verdad y al menos
uno de los vendedores logró vender 6
autos entonces el mínimo tiene que ser
más chico o igual que 6 verdad no puede
ser algo más grande entonces
definitivamente esto que supusimos no
puede ser y lo mismo pasaría si por
ejemplo
si suponemos que el máximo fuera 12 o 13
o algo más grande entonces el mínimo
aumenta verdad en cualquiera de los
casos es más grande que 6
como la suposición no puede ser cierta
entonces el enunciado es falso y así es
como nosotros resolvemos este problema